pues han informado que les han
comunicado a los habitantes de la ciudad
cercanas a esta zona costera de
Charleston Carolina del Sur y de Milton
Beach que reunía del Sur que por favor
no recojan los restos del globo que cayó
en el mar precisamente Para evitar
contacto con los estadounidenses de esa
Región del país y entonces están
insistiendo que por favor se mantengan
lejos de esos restos esos restos van a
ser traídos directamente acá Virginia
muy cerca a Washington en cuántico
concretamente donde queda la sede de el
FBI para ser investigados lo que dicen
oficiales de inteligencia a medios
nacionales es que aunque el gobierno
chino diga que estos globos simplemente
se desviaron y estaban recolectando
información climática Pues los oficiales
de inteligencia dicen que estaban
equipados estos globos con tecnología
bastante avanzada de comunicación y
tenían capacidad de interceptar y robar
información confidencial sobre todo
porque estaban volando recordemos zonas
muy cercanas a Oasis aéreas y bases
militares estadounidenses y esto era lo
que le preocupaba al gobierno
estadounidense que terminó derivando
estos globos que se rumora además hay
también presencia de estos globos no
solamente en Canadá sino también en
América Latina